well a life well-lived would be it seems
to me first of all to include some
element of reflection critical
reflection on what one believes about
fundamental moral questions about
obligations to one's fellow citizens
then beyond its but it should be the
kind of reflection that draws upon the
moral traditions in histories that one
inhabits I don't think there there is a
certain ideal of intercultural dialogue
that people have that say let's try to
precipitate out of all of our
differences the things we can agree on
and live by that commonality I think
that's a spirit and thin commonality
because it doesn't really connect very
deeply with what people care about in
the first place so I think a life
well-lived is a life of reflection on
one's own moral convictions and
traditions and not only reflection in
the sense of thinking but also learning
you know it's not really possible to
have a dialogue across civilizations or
cultures unless the participants have
some deep serious understanding of their
own traditions that I think is the
biggest obstacle now to understand
mutual understanding among civilizations
and cultures it's not just that we don't
know enough about this other society
it's that we don't know enough about our
own traditions to to carry on a serious
dialogue with different societies
different cultures different religious
faiths
so I think a life well-lived depends on
reflection and learning about one's own
traditions and doing so in a way that is
open to the world that is alive to other
ways wider horizon
and so I think a life well-lived the
shape of that I think can vary one
historical period to the next because if
we go back to to the athenian city-state
to be alive to the wider world would be
to attend to the way they did things in
sparta
that was what comparative politics or
sociology consisted of then today to
reflect seriously on one's own way of
life with an openness to wider horizons
requires being alive to to the world as
a whole to the Confucian tradition and
to the Islamic tradition as well as to
the Hindu and Christian and Jewish and
other traditions and secular
enlightenment traditions but I think it
has to begin by a serious understanding
of one's own traditions national
traditions religious traditions historic
traditions and that reflection can
proceed outward from there and I would
also I suppose the other element of a
life well-lived is not just a matter of
reflecting and in attending to other
ways of life it's also I think a life of
active engagement in what the Greeks
called the life of the city today we
would call the life of the world actual
engagement in participation in civic
life whether it's local or whether it's
national or whether it has some global
dimension
you